[Musique]
les techniques de maquillage et de
beauté sur youtube ont tellement évolué
et qu'il est devenu dangereux de les
apprenants n'importe qui l'état de
décider d'interdire toutes ces vidéos
mais plutôt que de perdre ses
compétences à jamais il neige à bonne
idée de les mettre au service des
citoyens par le biais d'une unité
spéciale
voici leur histoire
shera la situation est plus que critique
si le dr eran craque et 10 aux
mercenaires tout ce qu'il sait nous
sommes perdus j'ai besoin de votre aide
je vous ai déjà parlé de notre
spécialiste de l'apparence non elle est
très photogénique
il est impossible de prendre une
mauvaise photo d'elle même sur les
caméras de surveillance
elle est toujours en flèche incroyable
ce n'est pas tout nous avons aussi notre
spécialiste du en ligne elle peut tout
faire rentrer dans une valise ou même un
sac
sinon nous avons notre spécialiste en
modification capillaire elle fait ce
qu'elle veut de sa chevelure se faire
une coupe en forme de clé pour une porte
par exemple puis ceux qui râlent au
temps presse toutes ces filles sont
extraordinaires certes mais nous devons
surtout prendre une décision je voulais
juste vous entendra dire qu'elles sont
extraordinaires quoi si je vous disais
que la meilleure est déjà sur le coup
bien je le croyais qu'elle acceptait
plus beau qu'une mission
estimez-vous chanceux
[Musique]
bon là on commence vraiment à perdre
patience
ah ouais fait nous les codes si je vous
donne les codes votre patron à tout
faire sauter c'est un malade et je tire
une balle dans le genou a peut-être que
ça va faire parler le fait ça fait ça
mais ça il va tout faire sauter je vous
dis même vous j'en ai un
vous n'êtes que tu buzz
oui je suis sauvé pas tout à fait
qu'est ce que vous faites j'ai le maquis
afin qu'on ait l'impression qu'il fait
une sieste c'est habitera les soupçons
bien joué
et maintenant je maquille cette chienlit
pour justifier le fait qu'ils se soient
endormis
incroyable ne perdons pas de temps j'ai
tout on est fichu tout va bien se passer
tant que je n'ai pas les codes personne
ne partira d'ici là vit à l'ère de
réussir ou youtube
qui l'aurait cru alors comment s'en fout
c'est ça hein noam et c'est times way
home exploitait nathalie demissy ça mais
dix ans j'ai travaillé autant qu'un
adulte
tous les soirs je testais déjouer tous
les soirs noam à des nouveaux hans peter
vous devinerez jamais ou noam s'est
baigné et qu'est-ce que j'en tire moi
tout ça mes parents sont séparés j'ai
jamais vu un gentil [ __ ] de vidéos et
gdf tout l'état de rio en juin
alors maintenant c'est à moi de jouer
avec les gens ah ouais c'est mon tour et
je vais tout faire péter
alberto verme était allé au [ __ ] je
suis là
ou peut-être là et ben alors nos âmes
je croyais que tu voulais jouer
[Musique]
fin du game noam kong
il a passé
thibault
les gars
quant à lui
[Musique]
vous savez tous sauvés je n'ai fait que
mon devoir
vous savez que j'avais une chaîne
youtube à l'époque ah oui ouais je
faisais de la de maxime de microscopes a
salué les pelos quelque chose de nouveau
à 6 et 10 300 non non ça c'est pas une
vraie question c'est la phrase que je
disais au début de vidéo répond c'est
quand même non
[Musique]